good thank you how are you what are you
looking forward to this evening are you
all through the same person yeah I'm
looking forward to seeing ellie kemper
and celebrating all the the great
nominees and winners and tonight's all
about celebrating women and can you
complete this sentence for me the best
thing about being a woman is our
strength
yeah yeah and I think it's an exciting
time to be a woman where we're realizing
more and more that there's like Gloria
Steinem quote we became the men we
wanted to marry but I think I'm
realizing that's not true I think women
are just badasses and owning it more
yeah I'm tonight I thought 12th glamour
Awards if you could go back in time and
give your 12 year old self one piece of
advice what would it be to get
vaccinated for HPV that's great advice
very solid advice and if you see in if
Awards like this if you see someone and
you're not quite sure if you've been
introduced to them before how did you
start up so good to see you that's what
you need it's pretty good but then when
someone says it to me I know they have
no idea who I am yeah oh yeah busted
[Music]